was like first of all bringing this
movie to life and then what kind of
responsibility comes with a story like
especially being last well there's a
huge responsibility and people will
remind you constantly when we were home
shot the movie in Boston to get it right
but they knew what our intentions were
and how committed we were to getting it
right and you know the other message of
course was you know show them who we are
make us proud and show them what it
means to be Boston strong um this is a
horrible horrible tragedy but people
came together in a way that you know
certainly makes me extremely proud to be
a Bostonian too good to talk to the
Boston accent again good uh comes back
pretty quick yeah you know I think as
human beings sometimes I mean as you get
older kind of changes but there's a
certain amount of immortality in
addition I think sometimes you can take
being able-bodied for granted family for
granted sometimes how did this movie and
filming it and talking all the victims
kind of put that stuff in the context um
you're marking I've been fortunate to
have gotten to do three thumbs about
real people people who've been hurt
people who've lost loved ones and and
it's incredibly inspirational for us and
you know just to meet with people like
Patrick downs and Jessica downs this
young couple who you know just beginning
their marriage they were both getting
ready to move to San Francisco or he was
going to become a psychiatrist and she's
an oncology nurse and everything just as
beautiful young couple who get you know
blown up and with it within seconds of
lost her legs and her fighting to stay
alive and when when you meet people that
have gone through that you meet someone
like marcus luttrell who lost you know
19 of his brothers on that mountain
trying to trying to save him it's it's
very inspiring it you know as it is
cliched it as it is to be a pretty so
appreciative of our health and of our of
our lives and our children you really
get that we I think it inspires both of
us and it's why we keep wanting to tell
movies like this it's it's deeply
inspiring I'm your dad is here you hover
tighter when you get off set after doing
that kind of stuff absolutely absolutely
you know it you know to make sure that
you're reminded of how blessed you are
and expressing their gratitude you know
they got an opportunity to meet Patrick
and Jess earlier and they haven't seen
the movie but you know they've heard the
story and you know it's me the first
thing I do every day I get on my hands
of my knees and I think you know I I've
got a lot to be grateful for and
appreciative of and you know certainly a
reminder you know because these are you
know this is my backyard these these
things are happening all over the world
and just to be able to have our health
and you know yeah comes at an
interesting time you know you seen this
movie you know police being celebrated
you know you see live footage of this
celebration and stuff going on when it
comes out of interesting time when
there's a lot of friction right now
between police and civilians and but you
see this group of peeing it people being
able to get together and is one and it's
kind of there's a people are trying to
establish this movement black lives
matter you know to try to unite people
unite officers what are your thoughts on
that dad it's really clear that what
wherever you stand on police right now
or first responders in general that what
happened in Boston just like what
happened in San Bernardino Orlando I was
in nice on bastille day when this truck
drove through a crowd of people happened
right in front of me and I I saw police
and firefighters and hotel employees
running out to help that um what we saw
here was the very best of first
responders very best to police and a
great reminder that there are so many
things we need to be thankful for when
it comes to law enforcement and
paramedics and firefighters and not some
bad thing I was very proud to be able to
focus on in this movie yeah but we need
to bring people together you know we
need each other
and you know if people are out there
abusing their authority they also need
to be held accountable but bringing
people together you know police
civilians you know race religion all
those things I mean there's a lot of
there's a lot of anger and a lot of
hatred in the world but there's a lot of
love and love will always win and we
need to come together